in the physical world that's very hard
to kind of get around because there's
actually physical items in the software
the software world though much easier to
kind of do this iterative innovation and
experimentation as you mentioned there's
still a lot of regulatory IP issues and
things like that now part of this is I
always go back to the framework of the
laws in the books are only as good as
the enforcement right I mean so the US
and Europe has done a very good job of
enforcing these laws right and that's
kind of why I think you're getting that
stifling that you're describing the the
difference is now in today's society
there's this idea of decentralization
right so we've seen that with things
like Bitcoin where it's a decentralized
system there's no leader to call in to
in front of Congress or call and arrest
or do things like that and so one of the
frameworks I've been very interested in
is Facebook came out and said hey look
we're going to do a digital currency and
immediately Congress freaked out in the
United States and called in a bunch of
executives and you know pretty much took
them to task and said no you're not
gonna do this and you know why would you
do this and all that I wonder how much
you know going along this line of
thinking of if there is this regulatory
regime that ends up being stifling you
know is decentralization of all sorts of
things not not not just kind of what
people would consider crypto currencies
and things like that but other types of
software does that become a more
important trend because actually what it
does is it very much mitigates the
ability to enforce the rules on the
books again not every industry can do
this wraps of physical items and things
like that are much harder but in
software specifically maybe that is you
know kind of the way that people and
innovators can fight back a little bit
to continue the pace I think that's a
really interesting idea and I think it's
a very important concept and I think
blockchain generally enables us to move
the next phase of innovation from
California or China or wherever things
are not being looked after right in
terms of regulations into the cloud into
a place which is stateless
and once we do that and they really
can't get at us for to prevent
innovation then surely we can we can do
a lot of good that would be the hope but
of course you can immediately see by me
telling the story in that way
what spooks people and particularly
politicians and journalists about their
story but because I ended that sentence
with the word good you and I could float
off into the ether and do something bad
if that happens and I think the jealousy
of states with respect to currencies is
as nothing to the way the lawyers are
going to react when we say we're going
to have a completely different legal
system that is not tethered to any
territory but is in this in the sky and
it's done through blockchain the the the
you know monopolies don't like you doing
end runs around them
and they fight like tigers to reimpose
their monopolies so the jury's still out
on whether blockchain can achieve that
goal of giving us a sandbox in the sky
if I could call it that where we can do
the experiments that we need to do to
produce new technologies and new ideas
or whether down here on earth
governments will rein in these things I
think you know I often think one of the
most profound things said about
innovation was Amara's law which I
mentioned in the book which is this guy
called Roy Amara who was a computer
scientist futurologist in California in
the 1960s and he said we underestimate
the impact of a new technology in the
long run but we overestimate it in the
short run and this feels to me spot-on
you know when the Internet is just
starting we start to have wild ideas
about e-commerce replacing retail and
replacing everything else and and we
invest like crazy and comms and then
after a few years everyone says this
isn't really working actually it's not
made much difference the world goes on
as before
and everyone gets very disappointed
you combust and then 10 years later
turns out the dream was right so I think
the same will happen with blockchain I
in about ten years time if we're having
this conversation we'll be saying well
didn't really work did it you know all
the blockchain ideas all the crypto
ideas they kind of came to nothing ten
years after that we might be having a
different conversation saying actually
it worked